After the Second World War,
the Netherlands had to
build a lot of new houses.
Not just to repair damage,
but to handle the population
from the post-war baby boom.
And the housing they built was...
well, it was pretty much
all the same.
Most of it built quickly, cheaply,
and to one of a few similar designs.
So in 1968, the Dutch government's
Ministry for Public Housing
and Spatial Planning
started to offer grants
for experimental architecture.
Because, to quote the
government minister in charge,
"Men weet niet wat men mist".
You don't know what you're missing.
Maybe they'd find a way to radically
improve housing for everyone.
A lot of the experiments were very tame.
You wouldn't really notice them
as you walked through a city,
they just used different materials,
or organised the rooms
or houses differently.
And they actually did find
ways to build better homes.
Some of the experiments
were the sort of
stark, brutalist work that
you might expect from
1960s or 70s architects.
Interesting to look at, not always
great places to live.
Some of those became quite famous,
like the cube houses
in Helmond and Rotterdam.
One of the final experiments
to get the subsidy
was built in 1984.
And it was very strange indeed.
The Bolwoningen,
the sphere houses,
sit in Den Bosch in the
south of the country.
According to the designer,
artist Dries Kreijkamp,
humans were not meant
to live in a box.
- It's not very spacious,
but depending on the person,
like, I personally don't
have claustrophobia.
But I have heard
from other people
that they have experiences
of claustrophobia when
they enter the house.
So, it's not made for everyone.
- Kreijkamp was more a
designer than an architect.
The experimental houses are
liveable, and they're still used as
social housing, where the
local government is the landlord.
But there are definitely some problems.
- Because of the trees,
the shell of the house
gets green pretty quickly.
Once in 5 or 10 years, they do
a complete cleaning of the houses.
But anything inside the house,
that's all for yourself.
Except for proper maintenance,
like the boilers and
that kind of stuff.
Or if the windows are leaking,
'cause that's one of the
biggest problems we have.
On a good rainy day, you can basically
swim in your living quarters.
The first floor is where
you enter the house.
The second floor is
the sleeping quarters.
Then you go another stair,
and then you get to the
bathroom and the shower.
And then you have the upper floor,
which is the living room, the kitchen.
If you have a lot of stuff,
you have to adapt because
there's very limited room.
So you have to use every inch.
Even if you measure, it's still
no guarantee that things will fit.
The two halves of each house
were built in a temporary factory
on site here
and then connected together.
These are made from glass fibre
reinforced concrete,
with 10 centimetres of rockwool
insulation between
the outer and inner hull.
Which means they are warm.
- If it is 20 degrees outside,
then it becomes 25 inside.
So we cover the windows.
We're always looking forward
to the winter, really.
During winter it's quite
nice and comfy actually.
I can't complain.
- Maybe, if these plans continued,
the third or fourth generation
of these houses
would have worked well.
But not only did they have problems,
they also proved just too expensive
compared to the economies of scale
for traditional housing.
Recently these houses were
added monumental status,
so they get a little bit more care.
They can't be demolished.
But that's only on the local level.
Not governmental level.
At least not yet.
- The surprising thing for me
is not that these houses exist.
There's a lot of
weird houses out there.
I've visited a few of them.
What surprised me is:
they're still homes,
they're still lived in,
they've not been converted
to hotels or short term lets
or quirky tourist attractions.
And they're not sitting
disused and broken.
The dreams of the space age
didn't all come to pass,
we don't all live in spheres now
and it turns out that there
are good reasons for that.
But some people still do.
- It's nice to live here,
it's peaceful,
the shops are nearby,
you've got a park
next to your house,
you can ice-skate in the winter.
We have good neighbours,
we do hang out,
we do chat with one another.
You get used to it.
It just asks a lot of adapting
to it. And being creative.